Thanks so I present some joint work with
Jenny colors carpet that we mostly did
well white more in the CWI in Amsterdam
so okay so entangled game so we already
heard about entangled games but just
like you know a brief reminder and you
know just you get used to some new
pictures so we have Allison Bob they
receive some input x and y according to
some probability distribution they
output some al and they want to satisfy
some function sum function video and you
know so they can share an entangled
state and they're not allowed to
communicate and what we want to know is
the maximum probability that the best
strategy for Alice and Bob to actually
win that game and so one natural
question here is and what natural but
complicated question is about parallel
repetition right so instead of having
one game they play and games in parallel
meaning the Alice has you know n inputs
x1 to xn bob has n inputs y 1 to y n and
each pair X iyi is the core is taken
according to this property distribution
P and they want to output you know n
times a 1 a and B 1 B 1 and they want to
win all of the end games at the same
right and the question is with what is
the best strategy to do so right and so
of course they could play each game
independently and if they do they would
win with this probability Omega star G
to the power of n and the question is
you know can you you know so can they do
better and so there's some examples when
you can do better but most generally the
question is what can we say about this
this quantity Omega star hedn so ok so
the standard view is that we don't get
these games and world to know what is
the maximum property that they win this
game but right now let's you know let's
talk about you know let's do a little
step on the side instead of being
interested in the probability that is
involved can win the game will be
interested in the minimum amount of
resources that of additional resources
that we give to Alice and Bob such that
they can win the game of property 1 ok
so that's a very general statement so
okay so what kind of extra resources so
extra
of this this shared entangled state so
for example you could allow them to
communicate or another thing more
generally you could allow them to such
that this state the state they share the
depends on X 1 right so we're interested
in this will be interested in the second
question but in the end I mean in the
end says I'm talking about parallel
repetition is how answering this
question help us understand the this
first question you know the probability
that they can win those games so okay so
and our approach here is that will
consider states that depend on their
input X Y so the state they share here
Phi instead of being independent of X Y
can have some dependency we'll see what
kind of dependency can have of XY and
will show that this approach will
actually help us to answer the parallel
repetition question and okay and or
results okay so I directly say what
we're going to show is that for any game
G on the uniform distribution meaning
that the questions of Alice and Bob are
independent and taken from a uniform
distribution if the value of the game of
one repetition of the game is 1 minus
epsilon then the value of the n-fold
power repetition is bounded by Bob 1
minus epsilon square to the power of
Omega and / some parameters that depend
on the on the game on the side of the
game and so these things are pretty
standard except that here there's also
like there's a lot k plus log else so we
call that k is the dimension of the
input space l is the dimension of the
outputs face yep in the classical case
there is this odd cycle game which you
can easily see it's simple to see what
happen oh
decreasing the probability for two games
with respect one either a simple example
in the quantum case which is you know
illuminating okay so there are okay okay
some people will know this better than
me I think okay one has a simple answer
yeah this is this for now if I go lo
baje game there's only two thirds for
one repetition and to even in the no
signal in case yeah so so yeah so so
even India so even in the entangled case
yeah so it works for two but you know as
n grows you know is the thing will will
decrease exponentially I guess yes you
can achieve tutor to the classical
deterministic value so one of these
games are uniform is too
yeah so I will not talk about this but
if you were just interested in some kind
of exponential decay actually you can
have some pretty weak such such a weekly
report general distribution because
somehow you can add you know you can you
can plug any general distribution into a
uniform distribution of greater size I
mean you can you can play with this
thing so if you're only interested in
something with exponentially small then
actually these kind of theorems go to
general distributions but like here
you'll have so instead of Loki would
have K and actually I mean you have some
other weird parameters that depend on
this property distribution which which
we can make it move very large good so
yeah and so okay and so here so all of
this is pretty standard except from this
input size K which you know which hasn't
appeared so you know it's not a problem
for example if the input size is equal
to the output eyes so for example in
these cases that you know the log k plus
local will kind of be the same but in
some cases you know it can it can worsen
allowed to parallel the repetition
theory so it all depends on your on your
applications okay so let's go back to
this picture you know we said okay we're
looking at Alice and Bob they have a
game and they have a state that can
depend on X and Y and they want to win
the game of property one well ok so if
we don't add any restriction if we just
say it like this then you know I mean
it's not really interesting right
because for example in this state Alex
could have full information about why
you know Alex good know why and Bob
could know X and here you know they can
they can trivially win the game here so
it's a little bit too easy so we want to
add them to give them these extra
resources but somehow we want to limit
the the joint dependency in XY of the
family of strength edition and so one of
the main part of the talk is to define a
little bit what is this joint dependency
what is the quantity that will be in
thing for us okay so quantifying the
extra resources so okay so we start from
a game ok so we fix a game on the
uniform distribution and we assume let's
say that the entangled value is smaller
than one now we give to Alice and Bob
some this extra state Phi XY so this
means that Alice and Bob share this
state so this is their the input they
receive the output they receive so they
get each ex-wife property 1 over K
square and then they have this state
that they share right and we assume that
with the states Alice and Bob can win
the game of property 1 and ok so what
will define as extra resources which
will be interested in the quantity so
extra in the amount of information that
these states give to Allison know about
each other's inputs so and more
particularly will be interested in this
quantity so what is this quantity is the
mutual information between X so X is
Alice's input and dy dy is everything
that bob has so this quantity here
corresponds to the information that bob
has about Alice's input X and also here
conversely this is the information that
Alice has about Bob's input Y so
assuming that Alice and Bob share these
states by XY ok so this is the quantity
will be interested in and now I'm going
to defy the information costs for
entangle game so on the uniform
distribution so what we want to say we
want we're interested in this quantity i
C of G which is the minimal amount of
information that these states have to
give to alex and bob about you Taylor
lead but to win the game of property one
and so more formally we have considered
the state's you know that Allison
Bookshare and registered in the minimum
amount of information that these states
that you know that Alice and Bob have
about each other's input when sharing
the state row
and somehow this is some kind of analog
to the information costs the notion
using communication complexity right I
mean for those who know you have this
communication complexity task instead of
looking at the communication between
Alice and Bob you're def interested in
the minimal amount of information that
they have to send them that they have to
know about each other inputs to solve
this communication complexity problem so
somehow you can see this as an analog so
we have this well no well defined the
notion which involve this disinformation
and you know it kind of you know it's
parallel you know it's related to this
information costs which no is really
useful in communication complexity so
you know we're happy and you know we
have so no we think we have a nice
notion to work with and you know you
know and we should be happy but actually
we're not very happy so first I'll show
you that this information cost doesn't
do really what we want and you know so
let's just try to tow a little bit with
this quantity ok so start from a game
CHS age game ok so we know what is the
CH SH game you know that the value of
the CHS age game is cos square pi over
eight and now we give to Alice and Bob
these these extra advice states so you
know so on input X Y so if it's 01 so if
they have input 0 0 0 1 or 10 ok so this
will be 0 1 or 10 they have 1 over root
2 0 0 plus 11 and if they both have
input 11 they should get 0 1 plus 1 GB
right and you can easily see that if
they share these states they can win the
game of property one right so the shared
estate Alex would just measure her
register in the computational basis
bubble measure his register the
computational basis and you know and if
they get 11 then that gets different
outcomes and easy there any of the three
other inputs don't get the same outcomes
friend so when they share this day they
can with the CHS age came with property
one but on the other hand you can see
that you know if you look at this mutual
information and you know if they share
the state actually this
doesn't give any information about the
other players input so I mean you know
you can calculate the reduced density
matrices or I mean you can just see that
you know for example if bob has a wipe
or zero then Alice will have you know
totally mixed eight here on her input
and also totally mixed eight on the
chef's thing and it will be the same
thing if y equals one so you know so
somehow it felt that it was a good
notion that you know the amount of
information that you give away about
youth other input tell that it was a
good notion but it doesn't capture
exactly very well the extra resources
right because even though this
information you know this mutual inform
the sum of mutual information is zero
there was some extra you know there are
some extra resources yes so if you
consider conditioning on the occasional
d so you know in a virtual facial
expression so the condition of a for the
first term and collision p it's
introduced envision I mean I mean
usually what you would do is that you
would want to know actually you think
what you would do is the opposite is
that here you would like condition on
why you would like to know the extra
information given by the state's given
you know apart from their input but here
like the distribution is uniform so they
would anyway they have no information
and here if you condition on a it will
also be 0 and here there's no so yeah
the normal information costs you have to
remove what you know a priori about the
other players input but here since it's
all uniform it's it's all 0 so yeah so
that wouldn't change but you know so but
you know it's the state of mind right i
mean we have to change something and
these you know end espanta t to make the
thing work so okay and okay and so what
we will do is actually something a
little bit weird so we have this we have
the same setting we have the you know we
have this shirt state but now what we
want to know the amount of information
that Alice and Bob know about each
other's input instead of just looking at
what happens in this here we kind of
consider like
a purification of this state and so
somehow we'll have you know so we say
that you know so we will copy this for
each Alice and Bob will copy this input
registers and we'll consider like a
large purification like a superposition
of the input the advice states you know
so the input of Allison Bob as well as
the advice state Phi XY and we'll
consider this this notion this notion of
mutual information which is here so it's
pretty much the same so on the one side
of this mutual information you have X so
no you have two copies of eggs but since
you trace out X bar so this is still
classical X on the left side but on the
right side now when we consider ball we
don't consider Bob like in the usual
setting but we consider Bob which has a
superposition of his input now so
somehow this quantity corresponds to the
information that bob has about Alice's
input X but he is now we allow we add
the thing we allow him to be somehow in
a superposition of his inputs why I do
mean best for position I just see the
input twice yeah but yeah but it's also
quantum yes so but it's something he
could just generate himself with a see
not right okay so what is true is that
the fact that it appears twice is not an
issue the only reason why it's twice is
to actually be able to trace out apart
and to separate the classical and the
quantum particle watch me he cannot go
from here to Allah okay yeah right no
it's right so I agree that she read
there is only one why it wouldn't change
anything but he's this is still more
powerful than this yes you could have
just had one ex in one line but then
instead of that being several may go
down there would have to be for the
first one you pretend that
exactly yeah so yes so it's actually how
its defined in the paper but this is
more compact right and it's also how and
this also relates to the quantities
which are defined in the next paper
because they also use actually this the
same quantity so it's just for
uniformity but yes definitely and if you
do like this there is no there's no
something very deep here and like having
two copies of of x and y it's just for
you know so that there is this compact
kind of a formula ok yeah so here
similarly is the information that Alice
has about why when she's in a
superposition of her exes right ok and
now so we define this superpose
information costs you know which is the
you know the minimal so it's the minimal
amount of information that is enough
super positive information that is a
leaked by the state's you know such that
you know Alice and Bob can win with the
state 41 so this new quantity ok so it's
not clear it's it's not clear why ok why
we define like this later there will be
some kind of motivation why this this
kind of definition works better than the
other one but ok first thing let's check
whether this definition still has the
problem that we have of the CH SH game
right so because this this notion of IC
was not very good let's see if
super-close information caused us better
so ok so again we fix the same advice
States here again you replace your 1 by
10 and ok so now when you're interested
in the amount of information that Alice
and Bob have about each other's input we
said ok we look at this big
superposition and the quantity we
consider is this thing and now what's
going on if alice has x equals 0 then ok
so the advice state will be no matter
what is why the advice that would be 0 0
plus 11 and you know so for for both 00
in 11 so Bob will have you know you
trace out the a part and Bob Boone
have distinct if X equal 1 if X equal 1
what happens so if y equals 0 the advice
state is 0 0 plus 1 1 but if y equals 1
1 then the advice state becomes your 1
plus 10 so here you can see that you
know if you just look at the Y the Y
wine bar register you can see that if
Alice has x equals 0 Bob will have 0 0
plus 11 in this register but if X equal
one here Bob will have you know half 00
and half 11 so Bob would now have a
mixtape so here what will have a mixtape
on one y bar and here bob has a pure
state on my own y y bar so somehow so
now with this definition bob has some
information about this classical this
alice is input X so okay we don't have
this definition is good but we know that
it's not as bad as the other one we know
that at least you know for this eh you
say it again when we take this weird you
know this is weird some of mutual
information we get something that looks
better right and so this problem does
not look Karen is this a good quantity
and you know yes like so what are the
properties of the superposed information
costs you can actually relate this very
nicely to the value of an entangled game
so you can show that actually the
superpose information cost of the game
is larger than you know epsilon over
over 32 right and like this is one of
the main ingredients of the proof and ok
so there's two things first of all this
wouldn't hold for the normal information
comes because we said that the
information cost of the CHSAA game is 0
Y its value it's not one so typically
this is you know the reason why we have
this super post kind of definition is to
be able to do this kind of inequalities
also a second thing it's also hard to
have a nice notion of superfoods
information call for general game when
you don't have the restriction of the
input distribution and you know actually
and you know it's not clear like
typically we'd want to look at this
conditional mutual information something
but it's not it's actually it doesn't
follow that easily to find a nice
quantity and information
theory that relates to the value of an
entangled game if you don't have this
restriction to you know uniform
distribution or now it would probably
work for free games as well but for
general games it's you know it's pretty
hard okay so second of all additivity
right so this you know okay so larger
liquid so the tikati is that the you
know sake of G n is equal to n times
sick of G so that's that's because it's
mutual information right I mean you just
supply chain rule they say things that
we have pretty easily right so somehow
because we work with mutual information
the things work pretty well and further
ball that's you know look at this mutual
information then the third step would be
like to bring it back and to relate it
to this value of Omega start gon and so
it appears that we can show okay here
there is like you know you know there's
like a disclaimer so it's not exactly
what we show but something in the
spirits you know we can show that this
value sick of GN can be upper bounded by
something which depends only in this
parameter T and not not an enfant the
important thing is that they think is
independent identified and those by
plugging these inequalities we get we we
get the result directly so then you know
that then the result just just follows
right okay so okay so what I'm trying to
show you is to convince you that this
work which is really you know showing
this means that this you know the dis
notion of superpose information costs
you know is is useful it is useful when
studying the value of n time in the game
right so okay so it's like oh so do you
have any quality inn in the same
direction of your your upper bound on
but only for one copy of the game in
other words I can you get it upper bound
okay no no so the answer is that this
works only because GN is has a specific
because it's a tensor product of n
different games you have you can have
some counter examples here where so what
can happen is that if you have a game
which is with high probability i have a
trivial game with which i went off
lochte won and if half probability game
for which this superpose information
costs would be very large then if you
take like with a property trivial and
would happen p hard game this new game
has omega star g which is equal to half
but the superpose information costs is
still very large so you can't go with it
so you can't I mean you could put
something on the other way but it would
depend on the dimension so it would be
probably you know it would be very very
weak so here it works yes this work
specifically because we're working with
GN that you don't exactly use the
superimposed information costs but what
you do use I mean it is the thing you do
use also edited or do you need to yeah
yeah so basically so the thing we use
this would also all of this will also
hold 2 epsilon said to some other mess
but yes so I mean it exactly these
inequalities but I mean this means that
basically there's a lot of errors and
excellence and things going on and but
is it is it sort of additive because you
round it back to the superimposed
information costs which is the thing is
the other thing we use I mean it will
also be with mutually I mean you know
there's also be a chain rule that will
work ok for me so they located about
your palm
I mean we don't know that this is tight
so you know it's probably not tight in
the next talk there will be you know in
the next stop they also use some similar
quantities and they don't have this lock
k but it appears it's not so similar
after all so I mean they look you better
yeah okay so okay so that's okay so when
so basically this will not work in the
classical case because there is no
almonds theorem in the classical case
but just to see that in the so actually
the problem that we have is this a
problem this already appeared in the
classical case so here the advice state
if you just say that you have an advice
probability distribution you also so
let's say that the classical way of
defining IC would also be bad so you
would have to classically superpose Bob
whatever that means it's I mean it's an
interesting question and it's not clear
we know what to do whether there is a
good quantity you know you you would
need to superpose such that there is a
classical human theorem and you know so
actually in the few in the five minutes
that I have left and try to show you
where do you use the superposed we know
where the superforce quantity appears in
the proof right so I'm going to give you
a little bit of insight about this
proposition and okay so we call that
this doesn't hold for IC and actually
just show you know like a weaker
statement is that if the superpose
information cost of the game is 0 then
it's entangled value is 1 which which is
already you know and then you don't you
know then it's a small leap of faith to
know that you know if it worked 40 then
it works for excellent that's okay so
what does it mean so
with fix a game G the superfoods
information cost equals zero meaning
that we can there exists a family of
states of this form such that two things
Alice and Bob can win with property one
when sharing these states and if they
share this other states with the
superposed inputs this doesn't give away
any information about each other's
inputs so that's the so that's just the
definition and okay so we know and the
mutual information is positive so this
is equal to zero it means that you know
each of the each of the parts is 0 right
ok so I know what will we do so we've
first row this lemma which means that ok
so means that Alice there is a unitary
so for all X there is a unitary from
Alice that can remove the dependency in
X of wealth and say her extra copy
that's easy but more interestingly in
the state Phi ex-wife so somehow there
is a local unitary analysis side that
transform any Phi XY 250 wine ok so
that's a so that's a first lemma you
know and how do we prove this so they
start from this thing and you know bob
has no information about super sauce bob
has no information about eggs so we'll
define Phi X to be everything apart from
this the first X in register X and what
does it mean that bob has no information
about X its mean that if you trace out
alice is part of the state's IX well
it's the same for all X that's that
exactly means that bob has no
information about X there's no way it
knows it so it's discipline and once you
have this property then you can apply 12
in theorem so this is just an
application of the limit theorem meaning
that if this holds then locally Alice
can transform side x into try 0 right
and then you can see that you know case
of tracks is a little bit larger and it
closed why why but then you can see that
the only way that this can work is it
for all why they think Ford so and here
is where like and for all of this
you know for all of this reasoning to
hold you really need to assume that
Bob's input is in some kind of super
position what am I theorem doesn't work
like with Mick states something I mean
you know you must have you must have
like some kind of pure state applied
movement theorem and do something so if
you would want to apply the same thing
in the classical case you would have to
invent like another model you know which
is stronger than the classical model so
that you know bomb could have some extra
information around here that will allow
women theorem for probability
distributions and you know so you know
the interesting thing to sing actually
you know I haven't developed a thing but
let but so just to see that here really
the super pulse the notion is really
important and once we have this than you
know basically have it all so you know
Alex can remove her dependencies and X
you know symmetrically Bob can remove
the defendants in Y by playing a unitary
view I yeah so here what we showed is
that basically they can go from phi XY
and if they each supply you x and v why
they can go from 2500 so now if you want
to you know if you want to construct a
strategy for a game then we just do the
opposite you know they start with 500
which is independent they apply UX
dagger and V Y dagger and they obtain my
ex-wife and by definition we said that
if they have Phi XY they can win the
game of property one so you know so we
conclude that you know the value of the
integral game is one so yeah so okay so
just to recap so this works this as I
said is the chain rule neutral
information and this is what I'm not
going to talk about because a little bit
but exact yeah lets you so I did talk
about it you know if you have an
intuition I mean you know if you're
interested we can talk about it it's not
very long and you know if you want to
see where this input size comes in and
jump and so
standard conclusion reflect the
communication co-creation yes okay very
okay so that's something I guess you
shown one special case of that yeah so
okay so that's that's a that's an
interesting thing to help right so you
know you have a x and y so you know you
have some box which is you know so
between two players and they have and
they have some amount of communication
right so let's say that they can share
some state file you know whatever you
know they have some communication tea
and what you can say is that ok at the
end let's say they have some you know
they do everything unitarily whatever
they have a state Phi XY so if you're if
you look at this add the classical thing
okay then UK so if you were just looking
at the information cost it would be it
would be pretty easy to say that the
information cost is is a lower bound on
the communication complexities right
because I mean if you look at the mutual
information it cannot be more than the
than the amount of communication at the
beginning there's no information between
x and y and you can also do exact the
exact same you know kind of reasoning
for the superfoods information costs by
saying the following okay so this is
like a black box we know that for each X
Y there is a procedure that does this
and now instead of plugging you know
these classical inputs at least start
from some over X and you know let's say
bob has a classical y and uses this X
you know as a as a control oh I believe
that the hard-hearted achievability
right you don't like achieving oh and
she divinity Oh No okay no we don't know
I mean Sorry Sorry let me know but it
was just to say that you know how you do
that if you start from the black box and
you start from a superposition then you
have the superposition no achieve
abilities are you an idea